marry her
um
my view is your girl doing only
I would not date a girl doing all these
fans I wouldn't even remotely consider
it not in the slightest
um but he's absolutely would you say
some Instagram pages are only fans for
free uh pretty pretty close to me to be
honest yeah the whole only fencing it's
freaking weird man like it I have I have
some feelings on that it's not something
I've really ever talked about but um
yeah it's uh it's not for me
um but I think he's he's absolutely got
a point in that if that is what
she wants to be doing and putting out
there then you know the man should
should have a say in that in terms of
the numbers you know 80 I I don't I
don't know about the numbers but um you
know there's got to be a there's got to
be a say in there but I I don't think I
don't
look people can do what they want some
people won't like me saying that bro if
you're if you're a guy I don't think you
should be encouraging your girl to
do only fans personally but look people
can do their professionally strong and
independent
I think it's funny when women even say
that because if a guy says that he's
strong and independent it sounds so
ridiculous it's just a strong
independent man okay dude
yeah it's it's a strange thing you know
if I'm about people just being about it
if you have to keep like saying that
you're something then it actually reeks
of insecurity to me like I don't walk
around talking about I'm a strong man
I'm an independent I'm smart I'm it's
just like dude just just be you just be
about it you know just just be it people
can see it if you are
[Music]
I've come to realize actually seeing a
lot of Andrew Tate recently I actually
agree with a lot of what he says
bring back the Top Gear how did they do
we missed out on the internet
he got banned you know for freedom of
speech everyone's going to always have
opinions aren't they they might agree or
disagree but I found myself agreeing on
a lot of things he said and that is
probably one of them perhaps not 80
that's quite a wild figure
um but as Paul touched on which I can
resonate with me personally my my actual
Instagram could be considered probably
is considered quite close to only fans
it makes uh I have a reasonable number
of followers I can make money off it
I think I'd be quite lucky to have a man
who would not only tolerate that but
encourage it so actually having him say
that would be something I'd be open to
because I think it's very hard to come
across a male who would actually
encourage it and accept it let alone
monetize from it so yeah I agree with
him wholeheartedly perhaps again not 80
percent
maybe 70. most of the work here and got
my foot on my head and God knows what
he's not doing that but if he's taking
pictures and the like and he's my man
and he's going to save my man and we're
going to be out in public together and
he's got to set stand there with me
knowing that men are paying to see
things that he doesn't pay to see
I can see why he wanted me on your feet
100 I can't disagree with her at all
okay what do you think
um I wouldn't do only fans
I don't encourage women to do it I just
think
that idea of putting a price on your
body I think it demeans women further
and I definitely don't agree with what
he's saying because I think what
undertake is suggesting that he owns the
woman if you don't want your woman to do
only fans don't be with her simple if
you're going to be with a woman that
does only fans that is her hustle it's
like you may be having something that's
not agreeable as a career maybe you're a
Trapper right and then your woman coming
into your business and saying well it's
quite embarrassing being with a Trapper
you know because I I work in the nine to
five legal sector so you know what I
want some I want a cup I feel like
that's unacceptable why would I be able
to do that so why can you come into my
hustle and you want a cup because you're
a man I ever I have a question when when
you get married or do you want to get
married yeah do you will you give him
control the money
no
we can share the money so it could be
right but like at the end of the day
someone's gonna make a financial
decision like like if one person wants
to buy a house and one person doesn't
someone has to have the final say
that's I I've never understood that
concept I don't understand why there
needs to be one like this idea of having
a one alpha man in a relationship I
can't understand it why can't we both be
Alpha okay
because okay if you're if you're gonna
run a company like someone has to lead
yeah if you have more experience in that
field say you you dealt with poverty
before and you know what you know
everything about this then darling take
it but imagine I have gone in like done
years of like experience and I've gone
to school learning about properties and
then you want to come to me and say
because I'm a man I feel like I should
make the decision I'll be like hell no
because at the end of the day it's about
expertise you know any women that are
good with money
I don't know any well when it comes to
saving women are a lot better than me no
they no they're not we we spend more
even though we make less
we own some we own 70 of Consumer Debt I
mean I grew up in a household where um
it's the opposite my mum has a lot of
assets more than my dad so I I've seen
it work where it's like a woman can
create assets she can save a lot of
money and invest and grow and build so I
don't and that's why I've never
understood it because I've seen a woman
do it so I guess that's what shaped my
belief okay okay what do you think I
don't agree with that statement
um because I feel like um it's coming
off controlling
why am I entitled to give my man what
I've worked for that does not make sense
to me whatsoever so in that sense yeah
no that's controlling it's because it's
because of the nature of the work then
don't date someone I would agree with
you yeah if you want a partner you can
find um ladies everywhere do you
understand so yeah yeah I I I agree man
I I don't think dudes should be you know
dating girls doing that not seriously
anyway but but people can have their
yeah well that's that's what he is
yeah
what did you say though like and if I
mean because that in that clip they're
dating but if you're married like I feel
like someone has to control the money
sorry sorry to cut you off you can't
have a democracy with only two people
you're gonna have a decision maker and
it doesn't mean on every single issue
the decision maker is the same in most
traditional families which by the way we
still need to remember is like probably
80 plus of marriages around the world
um the man typically has the final say
on certain things and the woman
typically has the final say on certain
things that's just how it is that's
actually what human beings tend to
default to of course Everyone's an
individual there's all sorts of
exceptions and personal circumstances
and so on but that's typically that
that's typically how it goes but you
can't if you've only got two people it
doesn't even matter if it's not a
marriage if you've only got two people
and a decision needs to be made someone
ultimately you can negotiate and you
should negotiate and the other person
should always have a say but ultimately
one person is going to have to make a
decision let's go you can flip a coin I
mean you could do it but yeah someone
someone has to have the authority and I
think the the truth is that women do not
respect
men who do not have a level of authority
this this is the truth a man who will
not lead I'm sure you don't like it if
you go out on a date with a guy and
you're like oh should we go I don't know
where do you where do you want to go
where do you want to eat what what are
you oh no like what are you right it's
it's lame it's lame and it's and that's
not something that's reciprocated like
as a man if a woman is indecisive or
what like that's not a turn off right
that's just yeah she's she's a woman I'm
I'm supposed to be the one if I'm asking
a girl out on a day I'm not I I I'll
pick the restaurant cool I'll I'll sort
this stuff out that's just
that's just how it is it's biologically
rooted
and yes there can be exceptions but
you know if
there's there's always exceptions right
I wouldn't expect a man to take a cut of
my money if I was working in a normal
industry no no way I'd be like how dare
you you're not taking my money but I
think in that specific industry where
you're literally why because he's
allowing you to do it I feel like
unfortunately yes you're married I want
the dude to make all the financial
decisions I don't I see the way women
spend and I would say I'm not even bad
for a girl but like I just yeah I feel
like dude should control money can I
just say my piece now yeah go ahead
well I think they should stop listening
to
how he says things and listen to what he
says because I think he he says a lot of
good things but I just think it's how he
says it just to Hype people up and I
think that every
wanted to be all nice about it that most
a lot of people would agree with him but
it's the way he says it and I don't know
who that woman is anyway but for
instance if it was I looked at
was it the only fans
I was checked out what it was and then
they realized that no because they do
cooking on there yeah and they do
bodybuilding on there you know they've
got women that look quite respectable
that do cooking programs but
because she said it and because he said
it everybody automatically thinks to
yeah
you know so as far as I'm gonna say if
you're if it was any other job
and say that they were married and
people say oh no but we're not married
if you're in a long-term relationship
and you're living together you're
heading towards that way somebody's got
a bit of decision maker and
it's always our money until it's the
women's money
you know what's yours is ours and what's
mine is mine you know because
if you're married in your relationship
surely
all the money would go into a pot
rather than
oh I'm not going to give him this
because it's how much my son's
grandparents
married couple they're married they were
together until they one died in the
other one died too they died and
I remember she always worked and handed
over her money to her husband
she worked handed over her money to her
husband and he always well he said oh
they had five children so the children's
whatever they grown up kids that was the
housekeeping so the parents give the
mother whatever the children give the
mother whatever they have to give her
but they could understand why is it that
she has to give all of her wages to her
husband and they thought was really
strange
and then one day he just said right
we're going
and it's built this fantastic house in
St Lucia on the top of this hill fan no
way she would have done that and she
spent the money and I think if that was
me
and I was with his only friends or
whatever I'd quite happily hand over the
money
and
give me my housekeep and I'll let it
work you do whatever you've got to do
with it because once I'm with you I
should if I trust any of my body why
can't I trust you my money
my money now until I finished talking
though so as far as I'm concerned it
doesn't matter because I ain't finished
oh right because as far as I'm concerned
my body is more valuable to me than
money I don't understand why women
they will share their bodies but they
don't want to share their money
so as far as I'm concerned she's out
there sharing her body to if we go by
that only fans whatever Sunday my
viewers hang in a minute she's out there
sharing her whole body to the whole
world how many people but she won't
share the money with the man and as far
as I'm concerned if he's the man and I'm
like you when it comes to religion and
he's the head let him deal with the
money and when people are going to be
offended by he said he's allowing it to
do that well that's his wife he's the
head he's in charge he's allowing her to
do that so as far as I'm concerned if
you're both working in your partnership
the money's supposed to go into the
house together I wouldn't even say like
oh eight grand I'll give him all of it
I'll give him every single penny and as
far as I'm concerned I'm trusting you
with my body I want to trust you money
is nothing compared to my body
you know and that that's my point of
view why is it so easy just to give away
your body rather than give away the
money as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible